well welcome to launch CMU and the
launch of the new Swartz Center for
Entrepreneurship it's great to see so
many familiar faces and friends and
members of our startup ecosystem here in
Pittsburgh for those of you who don't
know me my name is Dave Mawhinney and I
am a proud alum of Carnegie Mellon and I
hesitate to say it but I'm also the
proud alum of a parent of alums as well
so I'm getting a little bit old long in
the tooth but I'm here to stay so today
is a momentous occasion for CMU today we
enter the new era of entrepreneurship
with the launch of the Swartz Center for
Entrepreneurship and the first part of
our program will celebrate Jim
Schwartz's transformational gift to CMU
the second half of our program will
focus on smart cities and will have six
lightning talks from the exciting
research and companies that are going on
here at CMU but to kick things off today
I'd like to introduce an exciting new
video about the Swartz Center
opportunity it's out there through
creativity hard work and soaring above
the norm you can seize it you are an
entrepreneur whether you're an undergrad
a graduate student and alumnus or a
faculty member the Swartz Center for
Entrepreneurship at Carnegie Mellon
University is your opportunity your path
to success where you bring your ideas to
market courses for credit at Carnegie
Mellon are at the core of the ecosystem
supported by countless extracurricular
programs global resources and networks
that launch companies entrepreneurs jump
in to the Swartz Center ecosystem at any
time to build a unique path and collide
with ideas creativity and visionaries
also striving for success consider a
student while attending entrepreneurship
bootcamp he learns about the sort Center
incubator project Olympus giving him the
opportunity to earn a spark grant which
provides the capital needed to launch
his startup he then becomes a Swartz
Fellow a cohort program for entrepreneur
training
or a faculty member who through the
National Science Foundation iCore
program discovers how to commercialize
her research which then gains
recognition at launch CMU the Swartz
centers public entrepreneurs showcase of
Student Alumni faculty and staff at the
same time her PhD student earns
additional funding by winning the
McGuiness venture competition for CMU
students and becomes an innovation
fellow an alum takes full advantage of
the Swartz Center connects workshops and
gets mentoring from the entrepreneur in
residence who suggests joining the AI
coresight program during this program
the alum learns about the open field
entrepreneurs fund which provides seed
funding to recent alumni for every
entrepreneur every research project
every business idea our centralized
ecosystem creates unique paths to learn
network commercialize invest and launch
the next great startup the Sports Center
is a great place because with all the
resources at Carnegie Mellon it's all
being put under one roof and that's
amazing the quality programs at Carnegie
Mellon is the people it's the fact they
interact with each other
it's the fact that there is this more
community spirit here that's really
important and really helpful in starting
businesses students and faculty are
really able to come together and share
their thoughts and opinions and
experiences regarding entrepreneurship
trance seminars that were free and open
to anyone on campus was incredibly
helpful to me everybody has an
extracurricular activity that they enjoy
and that they're really passionate about
and they sort of combine their passion
with their major and that is exactly
what is necessary to be a
the Swartz Center for Entrepreneurship
at Carnegie Mellon University we we have
very lofty goals for the sort Center our
first is to be the destination of choice
for aspiring entrepreneurs both students
and faculty in other words we aspire to
be the best our second is to create more
valuable companies from the great
research and ideas that happen at CMU I
always joke Stanford has Google
Harvard has Facebook Carnegie Mellon has
right and if we strive to create that
blockbuster company that everybody
associates with CMU will create dozens
if not hundreds of other great companies
along the way and finally we will
leverage the 100,000 strong living
alumni that we have at Carnegie Mellon
if you're an alum I asked you to be a
customer a supplier a mentor or an
investor in another CMU company there
are thirty of those companies here today
please go connect with them now it is my
great honor to introduce CMU Provost
farnum's Ohanian who has been
instrumental in making this work center
reality Farnham
thank you very much Dave good afternoon
and a warm welcome to all of you who
have gathered here to celebrate the
launch of the Schwartz Center for
Entrepreneurship this is going to be a
hub for campus-wide entrepreneurial
activities made possible by a generous
gift from our alumnus Jim Schwartz Jim
welcome back and thank you for your
passion for everything you've done for
Carnegie Mellon and for entrepreneurship
at
we are so pleased to be launching the
Schwartz Center in conjunction with
launched CMU an event that exemplifies
what's possible when top talent
generates and pursues groundbreaking
ideas in a nurturing environment I want
to acknowledge a couple of folks first
of all the exceptional leadership of of
course several people at the Schwartz
Center Dave morning our executive
director and Lenore palom and John Kagan
the to faculty Kohler directors thank
you very much I would also like to
extend a warm welcome to academic
university leadership and university
leadership including Dean Bob Damon and
Dean Andrew Moore who serve as co-chairs
of the Schwartz Center steering
committee along with other members of
the steering committee or present this
evening finally I would like to welcome
Peter Stern and miles ready to members
of the newly just announced today
Schwartz Center advisory board here
tonight the advisory board consists of
twelve successful entrepreneurs with
connections to Carnegie Mellon we thank
these leaders for their willingness to
provide their counsel and their passion
for enhancing the culture of
entrepreneurship please join me in
thanking their leadership
you know it is so fitting that we're
celebrating entrepreneurship and it's
taking place just a couple of weeks
after the white house frontiers
conference that was held here in
Pittsburgh and at Carnegie Mellon when
President Obama and nearly 500 thought
leaders from across the country came to
Pittsburgh to discuss science technology
and innovation as all of us recognized
our national identity is synonymous with
discovery and entrepreneurship we need
to recognize the changing role of
universities not only as originators and
keepers of knowledge but also as engines
for discovery and innovation in fact
universities increasingly are playing a
central role in the innovation ecosystem
driving regional and national economic
growth and in turn economic development
and societal needs drive and shape a
University's research and academic
mission in a virtual cycle the vision
for the Swart Center for
Entrepreneurship is to amplify our
position within this ecosystem to become
the academic destination for faculty and
students seeking a culture of
entrepreneurship and opportunities to
learn conceive collaborate launch and
lead in new endeavors so my colleagues
here it's not a surprise when I say when
with our top-ranked schools in
engineering in computer science in
business in information systems in
policy Carnegie Mellon embraces
interdisciplinary work as a place for
early pioneering work in artificial
intelligence that started here almost 50
years ago we're now leading in a
development of emerging areas such as
robotics autonomous vehicles
cybersecurity data analytics technology
enhanced learning new materials and 3d
printing just to name a few
it should come as no surprise
that CMU has become one of the fastest
growing entrepreneurial ecosystems in
the world consider that in the last five
years CMU has generated 1,400 invention
disclosures a thousand patents 880
licenses and options and other
agreements and in total more than 200
companies that have been started by our
students faculty and alumni when it
comes to students indeed it seems that
no matter what college they're in
students come to CMU seeking to make a
difference in society whether through
startups new companies or social
entrepreneurship and they want the tools
to succeed we also this energy and
excitement from many of our faculty
young and more senior faculty in fact
most of our new faculty early career
faculty expect to develop new
technologies and engage in startups
ventures as part of their academic
career it's part of their DNA thank to
Jim's generous gift we will enhance
CMU's entrepreneurship infrastructure
and bring our diverse slate of programs
and resources to entrepreneurship under
this word center umbrella our pathway
for entrepreneurship includes
cross-disciplinary courses and degrees
including a newly launched minor in
entrepreneurship that's available to all
students across the entire university
regardless of their major regardless of
their degree at the complements of
course our MBA track in entrepreneurship
networking and funding opportunities
such as launched CMU and gap funding for
student and faculty and alum new
mentoring initiatives such as the
Entrepreneurship in residence program
and experiential learning programs that
take students out of classroom and into
real startup enterprises including the
James R Schwartz Fellows Program this
program in fact has been nurturing
talented student innovators since 2005
and we're thrilled to have the current
class of Schwartz fellows here with us
as well as several swar
alumni I would like to ask these men and
women please stand and be recognized
Schwartz follows
you know I'm gonna go off-script for a
second the truth is that while we're
launching this reward center for
entrepreneurship Jim Schwartz has been
passionate about entrepreneurship about
this institution in fact the Schwartz
fellows are a great example of how he
has been giving and contributing to the
intellectual development of this
community and supporting our
entrepreneurs back to the script and of
course another vital experiential
learning in his project Olympus the
incubator of the Schwartz center that
Lenoir palom founded in 2007 and has has
since helped over 130 companies get off
ground put together taken together these
programs resources and opportunities
work cohesively to accelerate promising
research and nurture groundbreaking
ideas at their inception the Schwartz
Center for Entrepreneurship will ensure
that the CMU's strengthen
entrepreneurship technology transfer and
economic development continues to
provide a vital bridge from research to
practice Jim I want to thank you again
once again for your incredible
generosity to and passion for this
university it is now my great pleasure
to invite dr. subra Suresh the ninth
president of Carnegie Mellon University
to the podium dr. Suresh
Thank You forum
good afternoon everyone I want to
welcome everyone to this wonderful event
this is a culmination of a conversation
that began three years ago in San
Francisco and it was the first time I
met Jim Schwartz and it was an
extraordinary journey Jim thank you for
from that conversation to where we are
today I would also like to start by
thanking Bob Damon and Ann powers were
sitting there who've been very helpful
in coordinating conversations with Jim
for many years thank you Thank You Ann
and thank you Bob before I touch on how
significant this Center is I want to
echo my thanks to all of those who have
contributed and worked hard to bring
this entrepreneurship Center into
existence entrepreneurship is in the DNA
of Carnegie Mellon University
that's everybody knows this but that
alone may not be sufficient how do we
take the DNA how to nurture it how to
help it so that a broad cross-section of
people all across campus especially
across disciplinary boundaries have an
opportunity to contribute and develop
their entrepreneurial skills through
curricular activities through planned
encounters through serendipitous
encounters through networking
opportunities through connections I
think I think these are very important
activities as the video that Dave showed
at the beginning try to highlight going
forward the best way an entrepreneur can
develop their business idea will be
through Carnegie Mellon soir
Center for Entrepreneurship in the video
they've also talked about the iCore
nodes around the country and trying to
connect excellent activities that
protect place at Carnegie Mellon
University with activities across the
country will be another pivotal part of
the SWOT Center for Entrepreneurship in
fact we have one of the cofounders of I
Corps who helped support it is on the
SWAT Center entrepreneurship board so we
are very excited about the possibility
that this external advisory board for
the Entrepreneurship Center brings us we
are also confident in this activity
because the Swartz Sentra epitomizes
CMU's greatest strength our unique
interdisciplinary approach to
problem-solving the center will draw CMU
researchers faculty and students from
across our campus to develop business
ideas and launch startups you'll support
our alumni entrepreneurs wherever they
are in their careers we very much hope
that alumni and Friends of Carnegie
Mellon University will engage with us
and will contribute ideas that will
shape the future evolution of the
entrepreneurship Center our commitment
to creating a new model for business
development aligns with University
priorities laid out in our strategic
plan to cultivate the Entrepreneurship
that exists all across campus through a
variety of curricular and non curricular
activities I mentioned the strategic
plan here which is the culmination of
effort by the campus community for me
for over a year because the strategic
plan touches on various initiatives that
the SWAT Center will feed into
especially the core core priorities of a
acting and retaining outstanding and
diverse talent enhancing the CMU
experience and building excellence
across the university this investment
promises to have a transformative effect
both in nurturing the next generation of
entrepreneurs and in building on the
university strengths in collaborative
research and education across different
academic fields and disciplines that's
the vision that Jim Schwartz had in mind
when we talked about the possibility of
creating this wonderful Center through
his generous gift of 31 million dollars
10 million of which will be applied to
the physical infrastructure associated
with at a per quod project which we
announced about two and a half years ago
this Center will have far-reaching him
impact beyond the programmatic
activities of the university in a way
the center is a symbol of Jim's passion
and lifelong work a co-founder of Axel
in 1983 Jim is now entering his fifth
decade in venture capital and has been a
lead director of more than 50 successful
companies before founding axel Jim was a
founding partner in Adler & Company a
vice president of Citicorp venture
capital and served as chairman of the
National Venture Capital Association
which restored its lifetime achievement
achievement award on him
in 2007 he currently serves as chairman
of the Swartz Foundation and the
Christian Center of part City director
emeritus of the US Ski and Snowboard
Foundation where he established the
Borgan Swartz education endowment he's a
trustee of the Sundance Institute and
San Francisco Museum of Modern Art he is
also a member of the Board of Advisors
of CMU stepper School of Business
he's also the chair of the president's
global Advisory Council for which Jim
I'm enormously grateful to you we're
also grateful to Mary and I are very
grateful to you and Susan for your
friendship and for your generosity in
addition to Jim's many philanthropic
initiatives in education athletics the
arts health and social impact programs
he is also one of CMU's leading
benefactors in addition to the center we
launched today we can thank him for the
James R Swartz entrepreneurial
leadership series which provides a forum
for the Carnegie Mellon University
community and its entrepreneurial
Network partners in Pittsburgh to
discuss issues central to
entrepreneurial leadership and for the
James R Schwartz entrepreneurial fellows
initiative which fast tracks the careers
of CMU graduate students who are
passionate about entrepreneurship in the
technology arena with a record of
commitment like this it's no wonder that
we are here today to again express our
deepest gratitude to Jim and Susan for
their ongoing dedication to Carnegie
Mellon University I would also like to
add just a few months ago Carnegie
Mellon University bestowed upon Jim an
honorary Doctorate degree
congratulations Jim
to show our appreciation we would like
to present it with a small token today
please join me in bringing to the stage
a great and abiding friend to Carnegie
Mellon University Jim Schwartz
Thank You subra for that wonderful
introduction
I'm so happy to be here today for the
launch of our campus with center for
entrepreneurship many have made this
possible and we all have one objective
to make Carnegie Mellon University the
destination of choice for the best
entrepreneurs of the world I'll go off
script here one second i sat today with
the Swartz fellows and I asked how many
of them came to Carnegie Mellon because
of entrepreneurship it was a good third
of them maybe more that raised their
hands I think it's a really really
important factor entrepreneurship is
about creating value CMU has world-class
talent and exactly the right value
creation disciplines of engineering
computer science design and business now
we will have the additional resources
and talent to enhance and mobilize our
embedded entrepreneurial opportunities
well I cannot deny the catalyzing effect
of my gift this Center would not have
been possible without the vision of Dean
Bob Damon of the Tepper School and
president subra Suresh thank you very
much
it was their bold thinking that inspired
me to join them to fulfill their vision
and a big thank you to the steering
committee that worked diligently over
the past year to add structure to our
vision led by Provost Farnum Jane Ian
Dean of the computer science school
Andrew Moore and executive director
David Moe any thanks for your leadership
and for the full committee that
participated with you why did I do this
I've been observing the development of
entrepreneurship on this campus since
being offered partnership with a little
CMU affiliated partnership back in 1972
I think I wisely declined that
opportunity but I then worked with the
legendary Entrepreneurship professor
Jack Thorne during the 80s and 90s I
made many trips here giving talks
classroom lectures and always taking the
pulse I've watched these efforts grow
through the years with the launch of the
Don jones center the success of the
McGinnis business plan competition the
launch of project Olympus and the
emergence of the open fields
entrepreneur fund as an important
funding source in recent years I've been
encouraged by the emergence of a strong
technical ecosystem in the Pittsburgh
community foretold by the arrival of a
Microsoft campus of Google campus and
uber campus and Apple campus and others
I felt the time had finally come to take
these efforts to the next level so here
we are on the verge of a new era an era
with a strong cross-disciplinary focus
and faculty to match a faculty that will
continue to attract the best and
brightest to world-class academic and
research programs that will now be
complemented by entrepreneurship
programs that emphasize team-building
mentorship leadership training
networking and strong financial
resources
importantly funding for the center
provides for a much needed increase in
entrepreneurs and residents to serve as
active mentors and we anticipate
launching additional funding vehicles
that will add to the successful seed
programs now in place we have numerous
examples of long term entrepreneurial
success represented well by members of
the new Advisory Committee advanced that
they announced today these young leaders
will work with the center to accelerate
and to guide the next generation of
entrepreneurs finally we recognize that
it is critically important to build
bridges to the best startup ecosystems
Silicon Valley New York Bangalore London
or wherever CMU alumni have a critical
presence in that spirit I am forever
grateful for the team of core AXA
partners who have come here today to
support me and to support CMU engaging
with the strongest venture firms and
development networks thank you guys from
the bottom of my heart and thank all of
you for coming
thank all of you for coming today to
support this giant step for
entrepreneurship I strongly believe that
ten years from now
CMU will be a clear destination of
choice for aspiring entrepreneurs there
are many challenges ahead they are
formidable but we understand them I'm
excited to play a part in moving us
forward thank you before we go I just
liked everybody to give one more round
of applause to Jim Swartz what amazing
gift he's given to the university to
take us into the future